et pour en parler nous étions nine avec
arnaud benedetti les injecteurs en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
c'est une personnalité qui a décidé
finalement de cliver parce qu'il
considère qu' il ya vraisemblablement
ans il a besoin de clivage aujourd'hui
dans la société française et qu' il dise
on il occupe un espace qui était
l'espace
qu'elle est c'est qu'a laissée à
découvert d'une certaine manière marine
le pen avec sa stratégie de
dédiabolisation un espace politique qui
vise aujourd'hui à la fois réunir
d'écouter une partie des électorats du
rassemblement national et aussi une
partie de l'électorat de la droite
républicaine c'est que lille va être
attendu aussi sur sa capacité à
redresser un programme et une élection
présidentielle c'est aussi malgré tout
ils n'en font programmatique et
là-dessus certain nombre de ses
concurrents ont déjà mis en avant la
faiblesse de ses propositions à ce stade